[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Linc and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting blinks gonna get personal
that's true yeah I think this episode is
gonna why I know this episode is gonna
get heavy but first we should start on a
lighter note because I do want to share
our experience in traveling to nollans
New Orleans because there's some there's
a couple of weird things that happened
so yeah let's give them let's give them
like a lighthearted shared experience
that we have before I share a sadder
experience that that I'm going through
this week okay for those of you who
didn't immediately begin fast-forwarding
well actually first we should give them
an update on the next three weeks of
your biscuits oh yes now we were saying
that we were going to take a three week
break and we kind of are but not exactly
what we're gonna be doing is we're not
gonna be releasing through new episodes
for the next three weeks we're going to
be releasing some older classic ear
biscuits that you may or may not have
heard as opposed to just going
completely dark for three weeks some of
our favorites some favorite
conversations that we had right from
past seasons of your biscuits that just
feature the two of us because I mean the
podcast started as an interview format
but we would pepper in what now has
become what your biscuits is and is even
becoming more off right so we'll be
introducing those and then letting you
listen to those over the next three
weeks but we will be back with brand new
air biscuits starting on July 30th so
you think because I'm teased to this
being a heavy episode and then us that
they're gonna fast-forward through this
don't do that well some people are
naturally attracted to that kind of
stuff but if you're attracted to ghosts
or harrowing plane incidences or
beignets or beignets alligator sauce you
need to keep listening to this part as
well
alligator sausage also one of my many
nicknames in high school so we went to
we went to I don't say nollans that's
what they say if you lived there I say
New Orleans because New Orleans is what
you never say unless you're just a
complete loser so that's the thing you
don't say but I think if you're if
you're in the know but not trying to be
a poseur you say New Orleans but darlin
sounds like you just like a douchebag
I mean just between you and me do you
think like a douchebag when you say that
I mean thank you I'm sure that the
people of New Orleans really appreciate
it we need to try to say but you said
something much closer than that and we
had this exact same conversation when
when we finally got there and trust me
it took a while to get there
you were like here we on no island
you're like trying to figure it out I
put a look but no and then I'm like you
sell like a spec and now you're doing it
too hey something in my throat act like
I didn't do it to you oh you didn't call
me a douche bag no I didn't I just
thought it I'm too nice I had a little
something in my throat I just I was
trying to say no Orleans I said no
solids
New Orleans New Orleans New Orleans New
Orleans New Orleans New Orleans New
Orleans nollans fancy douchebag yeah
douchebag man your New Orleans is a
douchebag of a different sort I'm not a
douchebag bags on I don't like one when
I say them you want to be in the middle
of all the douchebags
there's a spectrum on each side of it is
douchebaggery and in the middle is just
mild douchebaggery because we're all do
so so tell him you want to tell about
the flight a week I'll be telling about
that too
yeah okay I mean you never happened
you've had more events happen to you on
flights and stuff like being stranded on
tarmacs and stuff like that but I had
never had any weird stuff happening in
the many flights that I've taken and
we're just like an hour into our direct
flight from LA to New Orleans and all of
a sudden it was like a movie the flight
attendant came on the intercom and said
if there is a doctor on board would you
please ring your Bell this light has Mel
C Hughes they were dangling the whole
time they were already how she knew
pulled the string with the Bell attached
to it
next to your suit and so then the next
thing you know did not pull our
strengths yeah yeah yeah I was tempted
to but then that's one of those things
that I make a rash decision and then I
realized that I've done a stupid thing I
didn't do it yeah and we were in the
front of a plane like a couple of proper
douche bags and so but this was
happening in the sort of the rear of the
plane and so we really that the flight
attendant run to the back with a pin of
some kind not a writing pen but like
syringes a syringe and I was like is
this an EpiPen is somebody having an
allergic reaction I don't know I'm not a
doctor I didn't ring my bell
but anyway about 10 minutes later after
some you know I kind of did the you were
craning your neck
rubberneck I was writing I know I'm not
a douchebag no I inherited that from my
mom my mom's a rubberneck ER man oh she
will turn around and look at one time we
were having dinner in in Los Angeles and
I was like mom the guy from that new
show how do you know his name is behind
you and her neck is like and she wasn't
subtle at all she was like she whipped
it around like looking right at and he
just kind of like a model on the runway
yeah so I kind of inherited that a
little bit so I was trying to do that
but then all of a sudden the captain
comes on oh sorry later gentlemen oh
we're gonna have to make a emergency
landing we have a medical emergency on
board right now we're gonna be heading
in a meadow a cow pasture the nearest
one we can find we're gonna be heading
into Albuquerque for emergency landing
and then the next thing you know it was
like the bottom of the plane dropped out
I've never ascended it was like all of a
sudden we're in one descended we were in
one of those anti-gravity experiences
[Applause]
except for the doctor and the guy who
was like oh yeah we'll talk about him in
a second we come down real fast it's
very aggressive we come in real hot
Stevie was sitting like to the scene in
front of us and then Ali our agent was
like four seats up and they're like
turning her rent they're rubbernecking
looking back at us like we could make it
yeah it was kind of scary
Flanagan I looked over at Flanagan cuz
he was on the plane yeah remember him he
still he still yes no he was over there
and I looked at him and he was just like
Oh laptop yeah he's I mean Flanagan is
laptop he is like laptop open he's like
Bruce Wayne is like you're not gonna
shake him he's unflappable so and we
should tell people who Flanagan is I
don't remember titles these are Co oh oh
yeah that's it it's a pretty important
one to remember
leave it to me okay so anyway we all
said we come in real hot and then we
break much harder and quicker than you
typically would what once we landed
there was some aggressive breaking that
will come back into play in just a
second but then they're very careful
about saying do not get up do not use
the bathroom like a douche bag do not
get your stay seated so we can get
medical personnel onto the plane and get
this person happy was having emergency
off so as soon as we land they bring the
jet bridge up they bring the guys come
on
and at this point Rhett Ling's over to
me and he says I think in all
seriousness you know the inflatable no
no I didn't lie died no you you you jump
the gun that was not what I said at that
point cuz he kept the captain hasn't
given some information to erase that
from your brain okay they take the guy
off and he comes by us on a stretcher
all I remember is that he had on cowboy
boots and he was unconscious I still
don't know exactly what happened but
it's a young guy in his 20s probably
mm-hmm
also handcuffs yeah a little bit of
handcuffs going on in handcuffs so we
have theories about what was going on we
think we figured it out
but we'll come back to that a second
maybe he was just trying to make his
trip to New Orleans more challenging
it's like if I can make it with
handcuffs don't think so
me neither but at that point they take
them off the plane another couple of
minutes pass and then the captain comes
back and says ladies and gentlemen we
have a little situation here that uh we
were in the industry we refer to it as a
hot brick hot break every came in real
hot or coming in and down sitting real
fast and we got a hot break situation
and we may or may not have to get off
the plane very quickly very quickly and
so then I I'm like I might grab him a
book sack and that's when I'm out from
under the thing oh and this is my point
isn't what I should say it and then
Rhett leans over and I think in all
sincerity says I think we're gonna have
to use the slide I wanted to use the
slide I was excited that was the right
place for me to tell that part of the
story but then he came back on just a
little bit later and did say we are
gonna have to get off the plane the
slide did not deploy but we we all left
the plane because apparently what
happens is if you come in real hot you
get a hot break situation it can be a
fire hazard if they can't get it to cool
down and so they couldn't get Fire
Department to look at so we're all
filing we're all filing off the plane
and as we you go up the jet bridge and
then you you you go by the the ticketing
counter right there what it not the
ticketing counter you know you know the
place right there when you get off of
the plane and lo and behold there's the
paramedics
there's the stretcher there's the guy
with the cowboy boots it's still in
handcuffs right there and they're like
not doing too much to it they're also
like three police officers are there
three police officer and he was also no
longer unconscious but he was still in
another world
okay and so every single person on the
plane got to greet him as they exited
the hello thank you thank you for the
nice detour mr. Han I love Albuquerque
laughs I like your boots I think what
happened so first of all the first
I told the story the first couple of
times I told the story to friends I just
thought that it was like a Conair
situation that we had like somebody who
was being escorted by like a marshal
nananana Nicolas Cage with John
Travolta's face kind of situation I
don't even know if I've if I if I've
wronged movies same year if I've given
you what I think is I don't definitely
what was happened I don't I don't I did
not get that no the dude did some drugs
on the plane
most likely heroin because is that what
this someone saw and it was bringing in
someone who was in his row saw him break
out a syringe and shoot something into
his arm at which point he began doing
what heroin addicts do when they're high
which is leave the earth for a second
and that's when they said we have a
medical situation that's why they
brought the cops on that's why they
handcuffed him because he was shooting
up on the plane the handcuffs were
applied to him by the medical personnel
because the guy did have a badge and
then he was brought out so he was not a
convict he may be now but he was not
when he got on the plane and that's why
the two people with him will look like
his parents and not like US marshals
yes escorting of course he didn't react
the case look like he had cowboy boots
with his jeans tucked into him and that
may be a sign of bad judgment but it
usually isn't the way convicts travel
yeah that's it man you figured it out
but it seems so obvious they'll do the
xxx listening shoutout to you put your
put your pants on the outside of your
boots oh and also don't do heroin if you
can help it
now there's probably some legal
disclaimer that we need to make that
this is all conjecture because we don't
really know what happened legal
disclaimer this was all it's all fiction
can we just say it was all fiction this
was all fiction it was it but for
entertainment purposes but we did
eventually well we spent six hours in
the Albuquerque Airport let me tell you
they have a great observation deck oh
yeah you go up an elevator or steps and
then you're up there and they have seats
and that you can
there's power and their seats and you
can see there's windows the runway you
can see planes yeah I mean you can see
for all of half of the Albuquerque
Airport you can observe the tarmac it's
beautiful it's amazing I wish I was
there right now
it really taken didn't spend enough time
I have six or seven hours to really take
it in that's when I felt it's completely
satiated that seventh hour and being
stuck in Albuquerque now I've got it I
understand it now I know why you live
here now get me to Norland we get to New
Orleans we we did our gig we did the
thing we needed to do on a panel paneled
it we paneled it paneled so hard we
talked about the products that we sell
on Amazon including palm hey boy well
that bombs in Cologne
it was so it it's so humid and hot there
and it and it is it is douche bag ish to
continue talking about how hot humid it
is we're from California and you used to
live in the south and you used to have a
point of reference for what this kind of
weather feels like and then a constantly
just talk about how hot and humid it is
especially with that dad tourist shirt
you got on well I didn't have it on in
Orleans you should have this have it on
now you don't have that thing unbuttoned
man whoo but it trickles down into
places you didn't know you could feel
yeah it's getting tickled it's difficult
to react l'm eight we sign up I'll keep
this short but we signed up for a ghost
tour because I'm like hey we got some
time move our dinner reservations up
earlier so that we have the rest of the
evening for a ghost tour a walking tour
of Bourbon Street and surrounding areas
to hear about ghosts turns out there are
a lot this is a booming industry you
signed up for this thing you start
walking around in a group and you get to
a corner and like our tour guides
telling us about a house behind us that
you know something demented happened
and they turned into like a movie or
American Horror Story season or not I
don't know which one
braaap is the sound I make coven when I
know which one whatever season now I
don't know what to say I'm just gonna
start saying wow some people on the
internet say words when they don't know
what to say they'll say words that's a
thing they're doing now I thought it was
but on on the when we're on one corner
hello and behold you look over other
corner other clothes are the corner of
the street and there's the same thing
happening and then you look down the
street and there's someone there's the
whole groups of people waiting to get to
the corner to have the same little ghost
story
I think booming business I think I was
ultimately bit overrated disappointed in
because I thought two things were gonna
happen I thought a I was gonna see a
ghost be or I thought maybe not see a
ghost but like be encouraged to possibly
see a ghost or just sense the presence
of a ghost right to like interact with
ghosts on some level and then be I
thought that we might go inside
someplace don't forget because that's
where the ghosts are there was I was
outside on the street there was an IED
the houses it was a vampire dynamic to
the tour - I thought maybe I could shake
hands with a fan but all you do is you
walk around nollans and you go stand
next to buildings and they talk about
what happened inside the building and
and it's it's a bit theatrical the BS
factor is very high it's real hot I mean
it's a ghost tour first of all so the BS
factor we're already at we're already at
redlining in the BBS factor but then
they just say and this is what happened
and supposedly and maybe some of it is
based in something that happened there
maybe there was somebody who got
murdered there but then they'll throw in
a fact that's just like and 7,000 people
were murdered in this bathroom and
you're like well I would know about that
that would be like a national yes leave
leave leave he's in the back of a group
like Google she's on wiki
she's like verifying I was like Stephen
just get into the tour I look over at
Flanagan you remember him
laptop Bruce Wayne brought his laptop on
the tour
topping it mmm he did not bring his life
he didn't he didn't I could tell he was
thinking about it though yeah you think
about working I love him now yeah I mean
we need somebody that's thinking about
serious things around here the here's
what I'll say here's what I'll say about
the ghost store just going in first of
all definitely order the hurricane or
two that helps that will make everything
all the BS will go down a lot smoother
just to clarify you don't order like a
dynamic and and catastrophic weather
system - it's a drain come on the tour
with you it is a drink
it's a powerful drink it it just tastes
like sweet tarts which I think makes it
very dangerous and but that will help
also you're probably not gonna see any
ghosts you're not gonna go inside you
just need to go in with the right
expectations and and and I think you'll
you'll have a better time than we did
but let's get to the man was gonna be a
a drastic 90-degree turn almost a 180 in
terms of potential sadness and
introspection but I think the best way
to do that is suddenly know is with an
ADD oh good so let's throw an ad in here
and then let's let's go let's go let's
go deep into the fields okay if you
would like to dress like link is
currently dressed there is one method
well two methods first method is to find
someone with this shirt and steal it
from them the second method is to go to
mythical dot store and buy it yourself
that is the preferred method that is the
method that we suggest and recommend and
not only can you get that shirt that has
nine mythical beasts on it that now has
a little snot on it you can get a lot of
other stuff we sell things that we have
no business selling and you have no
business buying but you know what
everybody's having a good time so we're
gonna keep doing it mythical dot store
mythical number nine check that out
smell mythical that's not the tagline
it's probably better than that
about I don't remember what it is or if
there is one I like that smell mythical
okay guys
here I go this has been a particularly
difficult week for me and I've I decided
I wanted to share it with you because
not to sensationalize anything or to
turn turn it into entertainment but we
all at various points in our lives deal
with the loss of a loved one or the
anticipated passing of a loved one as
part of that and that's what I'm dealing
with this week that my my grandfather is
is passing away I'm kind of still in the
in the midst of it well he is he is
still in the midst of it he as of the
recording of this he is still with us
but we're down to days or weeks and at
least for me I don't hear a lot of
people talking about dealing with the
passing of a loved one so I think I've I
found myself and you'll see this as I
share my experience at different points
kind of at a loss for what to do or how
to feel or how to how to deal with my
feelings and act on my feelings and so
for what it's worth I've decided to to
share my experience with you but before
I get into it I will say that if you if
you have a particularly painful or
tender wound associated with the loss of
a loved one that that you're dealing
with or that this could bring things up
that now is not a good time for you then
I would encourage you to not listen to
the rest of this podcast and that's
totally fine I just want to give you the
freedom and the moment to make that
decision before before I process
hell I'm going through this so I would
encourage you to do that too to stop
listening if if that's the case for you
yeah my my grandfather he he had a
stroke and and and then when they were
checking him out as a result of that
they found that he had brain cancer that
we didn't know about and a lot of it
that had originated somewhere else and
of course he's he's almost 90 years old
so at that at this point in his life
there's just there's not anything they
can do you just move into like a an
end-of-life protocol where they the
family puts things in place to make him
comfortable for his passing and you know
but because he's he's 90 years old it's
he's he's lived a full life you know
he's he's four he's fortunate to have
lived to that ripe age you know and so I
don't I don't even know what this
statement means but people will say well
it's his time I think what they may mean
by that is well it's not it's not a
tragic ending or so the my entire
experience I don't want to I don't I
don't want to inflate it to the level of
an absolutely tragic or blindsiding loss
of a loved one which incidentally as a
family we experience six weeks ago with
the the tragic and unexpected death of
my uncle which I mentioned briefly on
another episode but that being said I
the flip side of that is that this has
been particularly painful for me because
of how close
I am to my grandfather and I know all I
will cry at certain points and I'm sure
you'll give me grace for that but I'm
his namesake so he is he is Lincoln
Charles Lincoln Neil the original I'm
the third and I'm very proud to be the
third and to have named my son the
fourth which can be a little pretentious
like Kings at this point right that's
the joke over royal royalty now but it
says a lot to who he is as a man that I
was very happy to have his name and to
pass it along and if you're a long time
mythical beast you actually probably
feel like you know him at least a little
bit because he's been in a number of our
videos remember back in the day so two
at 2008 2007 when we did the viral boom
I might have been 2006 you can check you
can check out the dates I did not do
that but we did a couple episode it's
called lunch with Lincoln because our
studio and Lillington was just a few
miles from their house so Rhett and I
would go eat lunch with Nana and Papa
sometimes a couple of times a week yeah
and then we we made some videos sitting
across the table from him eating lunch
well because we we we decided to make 24
videos in 24 hours that was called the
viral boom got a meeting found a viral
video a little basally you could make
them a little bit desperate a couple of
points and had to go eat all right I
think we I think he explained because we
edited and uploaded a video every hour
television remote to us and something
about internet bullying I think was
another one yeah he explained for lunch
we probably went there for dinner too
and and we also would at least one time
we filmed and I've heard a couple people
say that this is one of their favorite
like old school videos we would go out
to his was at his brother hit Nana's
brother so his brother-in-law's brother
to farm and we would go eaten and he and
he was featured in that I think we
called that the like the fish fry or
something like it was my Uncle Billy's
fish fry and then he would also he was
peeing and Anna were there for
rhettandlink cast live yeah typically he
would sleep through it but he was
present and I think we at one point we
had an audience cam yes we had like a
secondary web cam and as we were every
Thursday night for a year and a half we
would do coming to you live from an
undisclosed location in Lille to North
Carolina it's the and then you would say
red link cast and then I would I could
switch we would do in everything you
were playing the music I was switching
the camera and I would switch the camera
to them and it would be like who are
these two elderly people in this
basement and it looks like that that the
dude is definitely asleep now he was
legally blind and he got more blind over
the years so sometimes you couldn't tell
if he was asleep or if he just didn't
care to use his eyes because they
weren't much used to him so he was
probably listening you know yeah so you
you may feel like you have a little bit
of a connection to him but he's
extremely meaningful to me as my entire
life growing up my dad was either or he
was on the fringe of my life or absent
and that was so his father papa stepped
in and kind basically as a father figure
for me and spent a lot of time with me
he would pick me up from school he would
he was the one who taught me to fish
he's the one even though I hated it he's
the one who taught me how to water-ski
you can water-ski I can water-ski
I can't barefoot scheme which he
considered that to me well he didn't
he'd take you out on the boat like at
least once and we did like a kneeboard
he took me knee boarding all the time I
thought that was our thing
yeah he could I mean we say in the epic
rap battle of manliness we're like at
the end we're like thrown a lot of brags
back and forth and one of them is I
could barefoot ski and that came from
the fact that he and my dad could I just
thought it was magical you could get you
could shift from skiing on one slalom
ski and then all of a sudden you're
putting your other foot out and then
you're kicking off the only ski that is
keeping you above the water and then
magically you're still skiing on nothing
but your bare feet crazy because I mean
literally he was walking on water that's
and that's what I thought about him well
the funny thing is I'll let you get goat
in a second is that my dad could
barefoot ski as well really I think it's
some sort of rite of passage
it was baby boomers in the secondly if
you're a man in the south and you can't
barefoot at ski you better hang it up
and he would he had one of those big
Honda motorcycles and he picked me up
from I remember that thing and we would
like the the Goldwing and I think he's
what it was called Honda Goldwing he had
like luggage permanently attached to it
yeah to a suitcase on each side and they
had handles and I would either hold on
those handles or I would just wrap my
arms around his waist and that's as
close as you would get to a seat belt
why didn't you just get in one of the
suitcases because the views not quite as
good from in there when my mom had a
horrible car accident and actually broke
her back she basically fully recovered
from it eventually but he was the one
who picked me up from school that day
he's the one that told me it's gonna be
all right he was he was the chief of
police in Luton and I always thought
that he was the coolest guy you know he
was the only police officer who had like
at his own office because he was the one
in charge
I remember our his neighbor was
one of the town commissioners and his
daughter babysat me so we knew them and
I didn't know what a commissioner was
but I knew that it was like something
like something important for the town of
Lillington and I remember I asked him
pop on one day I was like pop-up who's
who has more power a commissioner or the
chief of police and I remember he kind
of smiled and he said well politically
the Commissioner does and he left it at
that and I remember thinking yeah but I
know who's got the gun yeah he was he
was he was my hero
so this was this was tough for me it's
one of those things where you know as he
got older you start to dread the news
that you're gonna get the call and it's
gonna be okay he's he's he's passed away
so you know it was actually it's a
blessing that the call was not he's
passed away but that he's going to but
it's interesting because the way that I
processed it it's it's weird in
retrospect but I'll just share it
honestly that you know I thought okay
this is it I'm he knows I love him
I don't it's not like I feel like I need
to get something off my chest like some
there may be some people who feel like
okay there's you've got a said something
right or say something to bring some
sort of closure we always had the
relationship that where I would tell him
I loved him and he would tell me he
loved me and you know we I would only
see him once maybe twice a year
ever since we moved out here and for my
uncle's funeral that was the the last
time I had seen him and and every time I
mean for for many years now it's like
that time when you're when the trip is
ending whatever it may be like usually
Christmastime there's that moment where
you say goodbye and it's like you don't
want to make a big deal out of it but
you know that this could be this could
be the last goodbye you know next time I
see him he could be in a casket all that
to say my my first reaction was not I
gotta get home it was well okay we got
to get things in order there's lots of
things that we have planned that now
we're gonna have to ready ourselves for
going home for the funeral but as I
talked to dad and I talked and as I
talked to my aunt about how things were
going and he wasn't doing well at all
and then he got a little better and then
I'm thinking okay but you know it's me
it wasn't an active decision to say okay
should I go home at this point
to see him that's just I just wasn't
thinking that much about that and then
he took another turn for the worst and
they said okay this is this is he's
dying slowly but he is dying at that
point I remember this is I got up Monday
and I I got ready to come into work and
then I just lay down on the couch and
went back to sleep
which I've never the only time I've done
something like that is when I the first
time that I heard that when I found out
that Kristi was pregnant with Lily so
when we're going to have our first child
my initial reaction was I need to take
but it wasn't the morning and I hadn't
just rolled out of bed and so I found
myself asleep on the couch instead of
being in here at work and then I
realized like that probably that's that
probably says something maybe I'm
running from the reality of this
situation but then I got into work and
you were already here because you didn't
sleep in right I didn't took a nap and
you asked me how what the update was and
I guess I'm so much of a verbal
processor that the question allowed me
to just to understand my own mind and so
I don't remember what I said to you just
giving kind of the logistic update of
what he was doing better now he's doing
worse and it's he's pretty much at the
end and I think that says something to
the effect of I just don't I don't know
when I should go home it's not it's not
like any family members are saying well
if you want to see him before he passes
you probably need to come home they
didn't say that I guess because there's
an expense and associated with with
traveling home and then potentially
traveling home twice because you go home
and then he doesn't pass and there's all
these like weird logistics of well I'm
definitely gonna come back for the
funeral so then should I just wait or
but then I realized that you know I I
have the means to pay for a plane ticket
that's not really the reason that's not
really what's on my mind it's and I
realized it was it was the fear of
actively experiencing the pain of seeing
and I thought well that's he deserves
more than that
so I I think we were we were we were
talking about something else at that
point but my or you were talking about
something else that point on my brain
was still in that you know I was still
wrestling with this and I really I was
like okay I need to stop you I'm gonna
I'm gonna book the plane ticket so
that's what was I don't know if I looked
catatonic for a second but that's what
was going through my mind so that's what
I when I made the decision so I
appreciate you asking the question I
mean it's sometimes it takes no more
than just saying how are things for to
enable me to process and come to a
decision
of course I'd been talking to Christie
about it and I've been talking
specifically about going home but
something about that moment is what
clicked for me so I booked the flight
that was midday I booked it for that
night at 10 o'clock and then to fly
through the night to get there at 5:30
in the morning on Tuesday spend the day
with him and then fly back I said well I
might as well just spend the day with
him then fly back that night so I got
there for the plane would give me there
5:30 in the morning then I would get on
a plane back at 7:30 the same day which
is like a crazy dual cross-country
situation so I finished up the stuff I
needed to do here at the office and then
went home had dinner with the family and
then it takes at least an hour sometimes
it could take 18 hours to get from my
house to the airport because you drive
all the way across Los Angeles you never
know how it's going to be but in that
hour drive I was just I was trying to
make the active decision to say don't
run from the pain associated with this
it's it's much healthier to to lean into
it and for me that meant finding a
playlist that was called introspect
toons I don't think the word toons was
used so that is why you got into your
car yesterday the theme from The Truman
Show was playing I was like yeah this is
interesting link yeah it's like why are
you listening to the Truman Show
soundtrack I'm like I haven't even seen
the Truman Show that's a shame for
another time and I and I was like well I
I'm listened to lots of things it's not
a playlist and I didn't want to get into
it at the time but that's what it was I
was just trying to make the active
decision to be in this moment of
heartache and it was so surreal to be
you know to to drive for an hour and
then go through alone you know Christi
and the kids stayed back home and though
they'll certainly come out for the
funeral but it I just decided that this
just needed to be a me thing and to be
alone and I certainly was I mean to
drive that that far listening to that
music and just to start to replay the
memories and say oh okay I'm gonna focus
on this pain but also all of the good
memories a few of which I shared and
didn't it didn't to fly for five hours
most of which I was able to like do that
halfway sleep where my mouth gapes open
and I'm pretty sure that's that the
elderly woman next to me did snap a
picture and post it on her Instagram she
was my agent in your absence
then I rented a pickup truck because
when you rent the day before in North
Carolina that's the only thing they got
and I drove what amounts to another hour
down there and again just making a
decision to not watch a movie on the
plane not to listen to the radio in this
Nissan Frontier not a sponsor not a
sponsor the best vehicle when going to
visit a dying relative a Nissan Frontier
and then I so I get to the hospital and
it was I mean it was just before it was
like 7:00 a.m. this is that new hospital
in Harnett County and it turns out ain't
nobody there
at the intersection of 401 or 421 I go
yeah beside the beside of McDonald's I
go in there and there's like you know
you know you're supposed to get like a
badge and I get received at this place
ain't nobody there
my aunt called me and she's like are you
here and luckily she told me what room
so then I went up there it was I the
frickin Hospital was deserted I mean I I
said I wanted to be alone but I didn't
feel great that there wasn't anybody at
the hospital I'm talking working there
Harnett County people oh man they don't
need they don't need a hospital we don't
need your hospital I got to the second
floor and I did see one nurse which I
didn't speak to and I went into the room
and it's just weird when you don't speak
for so long and you're doing all this
traveling and then the first person I'm
gonna talk to is my papa it was just
surreal so I go into the room and he's
asleep and he just looked like death I
mean if it wasn't for the the blips on
the computer screen next to his bed I
would have sworn that he was already
dead and I had a flashback to 20 years
earlier ironically I was in California
for the summer and I got the call from
my mom that her dad my other Papa was
dying Clyde and so I got on a plane the
next day and flew home across country
alone showed up at the hospital met my
mom and went in to see him
and within within an hour he passed away
in front of me he wasn't he was really
bad off he was dying from emphysema and
complications of that so it was not he
was not communicative or responsive but
I was there when he passed away and I
was able to talk to him and believe that
he heard me but I was afraid that that
was going to happen again you know you
find yourself not wanting to be there
when he breathes his last breath I
didn't want to experience that again but
more importantly I wanted him I wanted
him to be responsive now I knew that the
previous mornings he was he was lucid he
was communicative and then by that as
the day went on he became less
responsive so my dad had told me that he
wasn't he wasn't gonna tell Papa or Nana
that I was coming he's like it wasn't
you can surprise him I was like damn
that may kill him that's what I was
thinking but I was like okay I'll I'll
surprise him easily so I sat I sat on
the edge of the bed again nobody's in
there except me and him and he's
sleeping and I leaned in and I I put my
hand on his arm and I said oh no just
kidding
I would the thought did not cross my
mind to surprise him at that point it
was I it's not like it was cinematic in
any way and or I was I was not so full
it's not that I wasn't self-aware is
that it's just freaking weird you know
it's like oh my gosh he looks horrible
it was really sad I made a joke but it
was that was not going through my mind
at all
and so I I woke him up and because he
can't see well I said it's linked and I
explained that I was there and that I
flew in to see him and he was yeah he
was he was pretty surprised I think I
mean it's it's hard to tell he was very
groggy but his his eyes even though they
didn't see much would just they just
flapped open like window shades and he
just he didn't he didn't say anything it
turns out that as I was able to talk to
him he was able to say yes no water and
then later that day when Nana got there
and asked him do you know who's here he
said link so he didn't know that I was
there and that but I that was
confirmation but I certainly knew that
the when I started talking to him and as
I as I established at my 40th birthday
party I'm not great at speeches I I did
give thought to what I was going to say
to him but it wasn't a grand speech but
it was important for me to tell him what
that I wanted to drop everything and be
there to see him that of course I loved
him so much and I just I shared with him
how much he meant to me and I could tell
that he started to cry which was
heart-wrenching but it was also
confirmation that he heard me that he
understood
and then I just i sat with him for two
hours before maybe an hour and a half
before Nana got there scared the
daylights out of her when she walked in
the room because she was she knows she
was shocked to see me there but it put a
big smile on her face and you know we we
sat there talking and she had brought
his shaver in too like he had like
stubble so she wanted she wanted to
shave his face he was always he always
had a clean shave he always had a clean
shave and so he wanted to she wanted she
wanted to shave his face and then she
wasn't good at it so here I am taking
over shaving his face which I mean and
almost like this the simplest of things
become the most poignant you know it's
it it's like your life becomes a movie
is what it starts to feel like like the
Truman show's soundtrack should start
playing at that point I guess because
I'm I'm shaving his face and it's it was
just a role reversal of you know he was
the one who was he was one of those
always there for me and even with the
smallest need her to do that for him was
a powerful gesture
so I spent I spent the rest of the day
there with him and my aunt showed up and
my mom actually came by to and and spent
a lot of time there and was able to
thank him for the role that he played in
my life and her life and there was a
there were circumstances that led to the
fact that Nana and my aunt needed to
leave and their mom needed to go pick up
Nana to bring her back so I had before I
left I had another half hour that was
just the two of us before I left which
was special I was able to reiterate a
lot of what I said when I first saw him
that morning and tell him officially
tell him goodbye without saying goodbye
no one's told him that he's dying
I think that we know his personality
he's got a worrisome personality so I
think I think he knows it but I think it
would have been too risky for me to be
the one to like actually tell him
goodbye so I said it in different terms
but and then I left and it was you know
it was inconveniently and maybe
conveniently a long drive and then a
long flight back so we're talking we're
talking an eight-hour trek when she once
you factor in everything associated with
travel on the back end of that which was
a blessing to just force me to process
what had happened you know so so it I
mean of course what when you have a
relative who's who's who's passing away
it
I mean but that death always brings
perspective at least for for a little
bit of time and I guess it's a question
of how how much impact can we the living
take from the death of a loved one so
that it it continues to change who we
are in a good way
as I certainly since I've been back I've
only been back for I don't know a day
right a little over a day it certainly
impacts the way that I look at my kids
and sitting there watching them interact
and I think the main thing that I've
thought is I want to live a life and
love in such a way that if circumstances
dictate that I know when I'm passing
away or and that that those that that
there are people that love me so much
that they'll drop whatever they're doing
to fly from across the world or across a
nation to see me one last time
I think that's it I think I'm I'm
grateful I know that many people don't
have including my aunt with the passing
of her uncle six weeks ago
I'm not aunt her husband my uncle they
don't have the you know you don't have
the luxury of knowing when it's coming
and so as a as painful as this was it
was something that is an enviable
position I know for for a lot of people
so I don't you know I don't want to make
I don't want to make light of that or
I'm very grateful for that
and I'm grateful that I didn't that I
didn't I didn't act in fear of pain
because it's it's a it was a beautiful
experience I guess I guess at this point
that's that's how I feel about it but
I'm not in the I don't want to be in the
business of providing application for
other people I'm just sharing my
experience and and that was it and I
appreciate you listening and yeah I'll
I'll leave it at that I guess well
thanks for sharing I'll fly to you when
you're dying but I'll probably die first
cuz I'm taller and statistically
speaking tall people die sooner so
probably ought to fly to me this is
assuming that we will not be dying at
the same time which is a there's a great
possibility of that that's true that is
true so it's also weird that it I hope
it's not weird that I'm talking about
this so openly and he's not any as of
the recording of this he's not he hasn't
even passed away it's not you know but
it's also cathartic for me I think I
have this conversation I process it it's
well I mean you know the and I probably
speak for a lot of you out there which i
think is what the way that you shared
this and what you're learning from I
think is is applicable applicable to
people like me and me I obviously had
very different relationship with my
grandfather's they were not present in
my life one died before I was born and
the other which I called Grandpa
McLaughlin like that's how I caught we I
called him grandpa and then his last
name to give you an idea of how not
close we were he was married seven times
twice to my grandmother there was
another woman in between and he was he
was just a just a just an interesting
dude who lived life in a very particular
way that wasn't wasn't about his family
so I think I saw him twice and then when
he died my dad flew there by himself and
I'm sure had his own experience
but kind of the way that those things
are hint were handled him in my family
whether it was a grandfather or an uncle
somebody who was even people who were
kind of in your life not to the degree
that Papa was in your life it would be
things like I remember I was when I was
like an eighth grade I'm taking a shower
and my mom opens the door to the
bathroom and she's like uncle Herbert
died
closes the door I'm like okay I'm
washing my butt and you know it I moved
away from all my relatives so it wasn't
like I grew up her I mean uncle Herbert
once pulled me behind a boat on the
kitchen phony Creek in South Georgia and
he played a prank on me he was like you
give me the thumbs down if you want me
to go slower and I started giving it the
thumbs down and he was like gave me the
thumbs up back and got up to like 50
miles per hour and I started crying so I
was kind of happy when he died no I'm
just kidding
no but I think that there is I think
it's very cultural too I think there's
this like scotch-irish approach to like
uncle Herbert died not how do you feel
about that mm-hmm
so I mean I think that maybe you can
relate to that not knowing how to
process those things but also I mean I
think the most I've ever actually
processed somebody's death was when Ben
died mm-hmm but even then it was still
very much a solitary thing or maybe me
and you like talking about it and
processing it but yeah I mean I think
ultimately what I'm saying is is the
your decision to stop go home
make a playlist as funny as that seems I
think it shows that yeah it's okay to
it's not only okay but it's healthy it's
healthy for you to process it but
obviously it's also the best way to love
him I mean my Nana is a is a great
example in the fact that she said of
course she's sad they've been married
sixty-eight years that's crazy in it
you got me and she was 1868 years and
she said you know we've had a great life
together and she's she's grateful that
they had so much of it and that they
experienced so much together and this is
another thing that they and
unfortunately or not unfortunately it's
the last thing they're experiencing
together and it's it's it's it's it's
painful but it's it's part of it and
that's what she said she said you know
we've lived a great life together and it
ends life ends and it can end and but of
all the ways that get in this is a this
is one of the best ones you know yeah so
thanks for hearing me out guys
it's it's been helpful for me to talk
through it so thank you guys I'm
thankful that we've got this forum this
this show is a place where when things
happen we feel like we can I feel like I
can talk about it you know I'm grateful
that we've that the show has more I
don't want to make this about the show
but I'm just
I do feel grateful that this is a this
table there's now a place where we can
have this type of discussion and
so thank you
[Music]